alors je suis sûr que vous pensez que
cette vidéo elle a été tournée avec un
truc comme ça ou même stabilisé avec un
truc comme ça et bien absolument pas en
fait ben c'est plein ils ont été
tournées avec ça et pis c'est tout et
donc je vous montre comment faire ça
après c'est un trou et salut à tous les
amis c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique moi encore une chaîne pour
apprendre créer et partager
dans la dernière vidéo je vous ai montré
comment faire de supers photo avec votre
smartphone lien dans la description et
bien aujourd'hui je vous montre que
c'est exactement la même chose avec la
vidéo tout ce dont vous aurez besoin
c'est d'un smartphone et d'un ordinateur
avec un éditeur de vidéos comme j'ai ici
derrière alors moi j'utilise finally got
mais vous pouvez aussi utiliser à
d'autres premières ou davinci qui lui en
plus est gratuit et les trois
globalement enfants à peu près la même
chose
allez c'est parti première chose ça va
être la captation la prise de vue avec
le smartphone
alors pour garder une certaine stabilité
et une certaine fluidité
j'ai opté pour le ralenti ou slow motion
je vous ferai une vidéo spécialement
dédiée au slow motion d'ailleurs bientôt
pour ça j'ai réglé mon smartphone pour
qu'il tourne des vidéos à 60 images par
seconde
personnellement j'utilise une app qui
est super complète qui s'appelle
filmique et qui est disponible sur
android et ios
mais vous pouvez aussi régler sur 60
images par seconde dans les réglages de
l'appareil natif de votre smartphone aux
premières choses 60 images par seconde
pour le slow motion et d'infini qu'on
pourra aussi activer une stabilisation
numérique qui amènera un peu plus de
fluidité aussi un peu plus de stabilité
au plan enfin petit plus toujours de
l'application alors c'est un achat in
app qui permet de débloquer des modes
log ou flat qui vont donner en fait une
image qui va être assez délavé à ces
termes mais qui va permettre de
retravailler beaucoup plus facilement la
couleur la colorimétrie après sur
l'éditeur ceci n'est pas un placement de
produit
je ne suis pas payée par film milk pour
faire cette vidéo voilà pour les
réglages c'est terminé il n'y a plus
qu'à filmer et ensuite on va aller
monter tout ça c'est parti hop
ok j'ai donc importer les vidéos dans
mon éditeur allons-y maintenant pour le
traitement alors au préalable il faudra
que mon projet soit réglée sur 24 images
par secondes et vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
alors comme vous pouvez le voir ici
final cut à ajuster les vidéos ou
regarder la vitesse d'origine
exemple ici ici j'ai pas de ralenti et
nous donc on veut du ralenti on va
cliquer ici sur le rush qu'on veut
sélectionner puis sur ce petit bouton là
et cliquez sur vitesses automatique
or vous avez vu que le plan est rallongé
vous allez comprendre pourquoi
si je lance à partir d'ici j'aime ont
ralenti alors avec se ralentit on va
gagner en impression de stabilité aussi
et donner un côté un peu plus fluide à
cette vidéo et même si je vais encore
plus augmenté la stabilisation ici je
vais descendre dans les propriétés de
mon run et cliquez sur stabilisation et
là il va rajouter encore de la
stabilisation numérique en rognant un
petit peu le plan et je précise quand
même que j'ai filmé tous ces plans
iphone à la main sans stabilisateurs
sans perche sans rien et le rendu quand
même plutôt cool regardez up impeccable
maintenant on va passer au traitement de
l'image alors je vais rajouter ici dans
les effets je vais aller chercher
l'effet net tu es pop ici et je vais
venir le coller sur montrouge le faire
glisser tout simplement
alors ici les régler à 2.5 moi je vais
le régler à 4,5 alors c'est subtil mais
ça fera son petit effet alors toujours
dans le traitement de l'image maintenant
on va aller chatouiller un petit peu
l'étalonnage pour ça je fais un command
6 et je vais déjà commencer par booster
la saturation parce que comme vous avez
vu on va filmer en log et donc l'image
était un petit peu terne mais ici ça me
paraît pas mal et ensuite sur les
couleurs je vais prendre les tons clairs
ici est allé les amener un petit peu
dans les tonalités aux anges et les tons
intermedia
r on va faire l' inverse on va les
amener dans les tons un petit peu plus
bleu clair que même les tons sont on va
pouvoir les monter un petit peu dans les
oranges très légèrement pour rendre
donner une impression un peu plus de
chaleur et sur les général comme ici
j'ai une teinte un petit peu verte je
vais baisser un petit peu sa voix là et
même augmenter encore un tout petit peu
la saturation
alors pour les réglages de colorimétrie
ses mégots à moi bien sûr donc c'est ma
sensibilité
mais bien évidemment vous pouvez faire
un petit peu ce que vous voulez justice
qu'il faudra peut-être essayer de
respecter c'est d'y aller
subtilement là vous avez vu j'ai monté
un tout petit peu j'ai descendu d'autres
couleurs un tout petit peu ça sert à
rien de booster et d'aller vraiment à
fond parce que ça va être vraiment très
très moche pour fignoler un petit peu
l'image et donner un petit look vintage
je vais utiliser un plugin
malheureusement sur canal que trop haut
on est obligé d'avoir un plugin pour
faire ce que je vais faire la met sur
premières et sur davinci ces natifs n'y
a pas besoin d'avoir ce plugin l'a donc
mon plugin s'appelle color finale je
vais venir l'appliquer ici et il va me
donner accès l' open controls à des
courbes de luminosité je vais mettre
quelques points ici et je vais venir
faire une petite coupe dans les noirs
ici pour donner ce petit look vintage on
va même baisser un petit peu là pour
augmenter le contraste up et il aurait
peut-être remonter un tout type voilà
pour ce look
tandja comme ça voilà impeccable et
enfin cerise sur le gâteau on va
rajouter les faits les torts box pour
avoir les bars comme au cinéma
letter boxe je vais chercher là je viens
le coller ici je vais vérifier que je
suis bien à 2,35 up
alors je vais régler l'offset aussi
puisque vous voyez que la tête est un
petit peu des poupées ici en haut je
vais ici recadrer un petit peu et voilà
ce que ça donne au final voilà c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas bien évidemment a explosé
le petit plus bleue en dessous de la
vidéo en tout cas merci de l'avoir
regardé et si vous avez envie d'en voir
plus n'hésitez pas non plus à vous
abonner et moi je vous dis à très
bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]